[Music]
on this Wednesday night the leader of
the Palestinian Authority grants his
first TV interview since hamas's October
7th attack Mahmud Abbas on Israel's
offensive and the lack of international
response imminent arrests in the killing
of a BC sick leader reaction from the
family of hard sing nider as reports
surface of pending RCMP action it's the
people that are giving the orders that
need to be held to account the
mysterious death of a South Korean movie
star and accusations that plague the
actor of an Oscar winning
movie and breaking down the year that
was a is for artificial intelligence
2023 from a to
zed global national with Donna Fen
reporting tonight Colleen Christie good
evening thanks for joining us we begin
in the Middle East where Israel is
expanding its ground offensive in Gaza
to wipe out Hamas all while the
suffering of Palestinian civilians there
grows gaza's Hamas run Health Ministry
says more than 21,000 have died since
October 7th and violence is also on the
rise in the occupied West Bank now the
Palestinian authorities leader is
speaking out over what he's calling the
worst mass displacement of Palestinians
in decades Redman Shannon has our top
story and a warning some of the images
in it are
disturbing a brome aftermath of more
Palestinians killed by a drone strike
not in Gaza but in the other Palestinian
territory the occupied West
Bank Israel says the six young men
killed were terrorists throwing
explosive devices at Israeli
troops MERS say they were innocent
bystanders watching an Israeli raid this
man said we found the youths some of
their legs were amp ated and their
bodies in pieces they were not
Fighters more than 300 people in the
West Bank have been killed since the
October 7th Hamas attacks launched from
Gaza since then the 88-year-old
president of the Palestinian Authority
which rules the West Bank has only
issued statements mmud Abbas finally
granting an interview to Egyptian TV on
Tuesday says he believes the death and
trauma of the past 12 weeks is worse
than the bloody displacement of hundreds
of thousands of Palestinians after
Israel's Declaration of Independence in
1948 abas also blamed the United States
for enabling Israel's operation to
continue by vetoing a un Security
Council resolution on a
ceasefire inside Gaza Israel's ground
operation plows further into the center
of of the strip and the South 85% of
gaza's residents are displaced and in
need of help Israel pointing the finger
at others for the slow drip of Aid
unfortunately to date the UN Aid
mechanism in Gaza has been woefully
unsuccessful because it goes through
onra Aid simply isn't reaching the
people who need it because Hamas hijacks
it and onra covers up for it some of the
aid that has arrived is in the form of
six foreign surgeons here to help some
of the more than 55,000 people gaza's
Health Ministry says have been injured
since October the 7th Redmond Shannon
Global News
London in Ukraine ke says at least five
people are dead and dozens injured after
Russian forces Unleashed an aerial
barrage overnight nearly 50 attack
drones along with Russian shelling are
said to have been deployed over the
southern Kiran and denet regions at
least 32 drones were shot down by the
Ukrainian Air Force but several several
strikes still hit targets close to the
front line including near a railway
station widespread power outages were
also reported as a result of the
strikes and new satellite images reveal
the extent of the damage from a
Ukrainian strike on a Russian warship
ported in Crimea on Tuesday the cruise
missile attack killed at least one
person Ukrainian military officials say
they destroyed an important Landing ship
capable of transporting troops and
armored vehicles they also say the ship
had been carrying Iranian attack drones
Russia had been using to bombard
Ukraine a new report from the glob and
mail says the RCMP is expected to make
arrests in connection to the fatal
shooting of a prominent Canadian sick
separatist leader the paper says
investigators have honed in on two men
they believe shot Hardy sing nider in Su
BC last June with their arrests coming
in a matter of weeks it's welcome news
to family and friends but as Nara
reports they still want more to be
done for the loved ones of hardip Singh
nider hoping for justice in his murder
at this G in sir BC reports arrests in
the case are imminent is promising news
within the community that uh there's a
sense of closure that might come with uh
with two people being arrested like it's
being said according to the globan mail
two suspects did not leave Canada after
the shooting death of the six separatist
leader in June and have been under
police surveillance for months and that
are SE m p are expected to make arrests
and lay charges Global News has not
independently verified those details the
way this information has come out now is
a bit surprising that we're still not
sure how the information or why it came
out we're also kind of very wary of what
India's role in this is uh that the
these two individuals may have pulled
the trigger but there's a larger Nexus
that was involved in September prime
minister Justin Trudeau suggested Indian
government agents were linked to nider
murder the Indian government denied the
allegations causing strange relations
between the two countries R but Canadian
allegations were fortified in November
by evidence in a US indictment outlining
a foiled plot to kill Canadian American
sick activist gatan sing banon who told
global news on Wednesday he still
receives threats I only know that I have
been the target of India's you know
Murder for high plot and they wanted to
kill me for running the kistan fom
campaign we are going to continue doing
it even if there are death threats us
author ities allege an Indian government
official directed The unsuccessful plot
to kill panon and that there are links
to nider murder as well as threats to
three other Canadian six the people that
are giving the orders are much much
different than the people pulling the
triggers uh and it's the people that are
giving the orders that need to be held
to account the integrated homicide
investigation team said it's aware of
the reports of imminent arrests in
niger's Murder but won't comment because
it's an active investigation Nara Global
News sir BC
after weeks of rotating strikes by
several unions Quebec has struck
tentative deals with the common front
labor Alliance The Province says an
agreement in principle on working
conditions has been reached with all of
the unions involved representing 420,000
public sector workers the latest deal
was struck overnight with a union
representing workers at several school
boards north of Montreal the deals don't
include salaries and benefits which are
still being negotiated common front
leaders are threatening an indefinite
strike in the New Year if a final deal
isn't reached the federal government is
preparing to hand over multi-million
dollar settlement packages to Michael C
and Michael spavor according to the
globan mail the two men were held in a
Chinese prison for nearly 3 years but as
Abigail Beaman explains hammering out a
total figure is complicated in the face
of a potential
lawsuit they spent almost three years in
brutal conditions in Chinese prison now
now Ottawa is looking at compensation
for Michael spavor and Michael covg to
the tune of $3.5 million each this
according to the globan mail which
reports Michael spavor lawyer wants a
much higher amount 10.5 million the two
Canadians were arrested in December 2018
Canada was unequivocal the detention was
arbitrary and the men weren't spies more
broadly the case was viewed as
retaliation for Canada's Detention of
Huawei executive mongan Joe on a US ex
tradition warrant but now as reported by
the globe spavor blames his detention on
kovick believing he was arrested for
information he shared with COV passed on
without his knowledge to the Canadian
government and Allied spy Partners
through cover's role as a diplomat the
allegations have sha a spotlight on the
Global Security reporting program a
little known information gathering unit
part of global Affairs a newly released
critical report by the independent body
that reviews Canada's security and
intelligence activities found the gsrp
operates in a gray Zone there are no
risk assessments and security protocols
related to increased scrutiny officers
May attract and the gsrp does not have
appropriate safeguards for interactions
with contacts overseas if the courts
rule that the Canadian government was
negligent in their managing of um of the
interviews with Mr sper that there would
be justification for the kind of
compensation that he is looking for I
mean after all his treatment in prison
involving being drugged and held in
Tiger chairs but experts say a financial
settlement for a case like this is not
common pointing to mayher arar as
perhaps the closest comparison he
received 11.5 million I'd certainly like
to see an independent uh inquiry made um
preferably headed by a justice of of
Canadian Court just to to examine
whether anything was done wrong neither
spavor lawyer nor kovrig responded by
deadline a global Affairs spokesperson
wouldn't directly comment on a
settlement saying the government is
committed to helping both men rebuild
their lives but due to quote privacy
considerations no further information
will be released Abigail ban global news
Ottawa the star of an Oscar winning
movie is found dead coming up the
accusations surrounding the tragic death
of a South Korean
actor just a few years after the South
Korean movie parasite won several Oscars
including one for best picture one of
its most notable Stars has died actor
lisan kyun has died in an apparent
suicide after he was accused of and
being investigated for using illegal
drugs as Jennifer Johnson reports it
follows a Crackdown on celebrities
allegedly using them in a country with
some some of the world's strictest
anti-drug
laws South Korean police surrounded the
car of actor Lee sunkin best known as
the man who played the wealthy father in
the Oscar winning dark comedy
parasite police say the actor apparently
died by suicide after being accused of
using marijuana and other illegal drugs
he claimed he was
innocent Lee gained International Fame
after parasite became a worldwide
sensation winning Awards around the
globe the film portrayed a poor family
schemed to become employed by a wealthy
family infiltrating their home by posing
as unrelated highly skilled
workers parasite went on to win four
Oscars Lee was interviewed outside a
South Korean police station in early
November after being questioned about
his alleged drug use he publicly
apologized to his family for being quote
implicated in such an unethical
[Music]
issue police questioned him again
Saturday authorities began looking for
Lee after his wife reported he left home
leaving behind what seemed to be a
suicide note in recent weeks South
Korean police have brought several drug
cases against a number of celebrities
and other high-profile figures including
K-pop singer G Dragon who was cleared of
any wrongdoing last week South Korea has
one of the strictest drug policies in
the world citizens are prohibited from
using drugs even when they're abroad
where the drugs are legal including
commonly prescribed medicines like Xanax
and
Valium fans of the actor quickly took to
social media criticizing South Korea's
drug laws and praising Lee is a
brilliant actor Lee has a long list of
film credits and after parasite he went
on to Starr in Dr Brain a sci-fi
thriller that was the first Korean
language show produced for Apple
TV but controversy cut his career short
leaving many of his devoted fans in
shock Jennifer Johnson Global News
Washington still ahead cleanup begins in
eastern Australia following deadly
[Music]
thunderstorms eastern Australia is
grappling with the aftermath of deadly
thunderstorms 10 people were killed in
Stormy Weather that uprooted trees
damaged buildings and left tens of
thousands without power the rain is
expected to ease by the end of the Day
comedian Tom Smothers has died diagnosed
with lung cancer earlier this year his
family says he died Tuesday at his home
in California Smothers was the older
half of the comedy duo the Smothers
Brothers he and his brother dick were
best known for the often subversive
Comedy Hour they hosted on CBS in the
late 1960s Tom Smothers was
86 up next the year that was the highs
and lows from a to zed
[Music]
smth but it's McIntosh McIntosh gold in
2046 Canadian swimming sensation summer
Macintosh has been named 2023 Canadian
press female athlete of the year the
Toronto teenager won a pair of gold
medals at the world Aquatics
championships while also breaking two
World Records before her 17th birthday
she'll be one to watch at next year's
summer
Olympics the year winding down means
it's time for a global national
tradition from the good and the bad to
the downright ugly Mike Armstrong now
with the 2023 rundown of the big events
of the past 12 months in alphabetical
order we start our look back at the year
that was with a sort of Technology
snowball that really just started
rolling in 2023 A is for artificial
intelligence as intellig gets integrated
everywhere we will all have superpowers
on demand there are both promises about
the potential of AI and warnings about
the Peril Hollywood's been warning us
for a while I I think I think AI is is
one of the biggest threats hi
Barbie hi Ken B is for sticking with
Hollywood hi Barbie barheim chances are
near zero personally I thought Barbie
wrote on oppenheimer's
coattails box office disagrees I think
the world Maybe wants to see Barbie a
little bit more right
[Music]
now C is for coronation did it seem
maybe a bit too formal for anyone I dare
Dominion to sue me D is for Dominion Fox
News Channel had to pay the voting
machine company
$787
million the Dominion machine that's as
filled with holes as Swiss cheese
telling the truth is easier and less
expensive lies have consequences when
the election comes e is for election
good good good good good good can't say
when Canadians will go to the polls but
our neighbors to the South have a big
one coming in November we got a lot of
work to do brace yourself they're
poisoning the blood of our country
that's what they've done this is
bullying F is for fabulous it's a word
describing someone who makes up stories
like oued Congressman George Santos I'll
be
back Farmington please now G is for guns
in just a matter of a few weeks this
past spring in the US shots fired shots
fired there were five cases where people
were shot over mixups for going to the
wrong door or because a ball rolled onto
the wrong lawn that's all it took we
just never expected it in a million
years the market is leaving people
behind H is for housing this is a crisis
if you're in construction things are
going to get busy they have to you need
to eat to live I is for inflation our
arguably the word of the Year shrink
inflation is painful too it's not
illegal uh it could be seen as sneaky
Dylan Brooks that looks good it is Jay
is for jumper as in basketball candid
won a bronze in the worlds this past
summer and is now considered a contender
going into the Paris Olympics we want to
win you know uh we want to win every
time we step out on the
floor K is for Kremlin which claims it
had no involvement in the August plane
crash that killed Genny
pran the head of a Russian mercenary
group had 2 months earlier led a mutiny
that lasted just one
day now L is for lukewarm which the
world was not in 2023 we have the
hottest summer ever 6 months hit
all-time highs and the year will go down
as the hottest in recorded history and
it's not slowing down antartic and
Greenland are melting well over three
times faster than they were in the early
90s
oh my gosh M is for Manitoba a tragic
bus crash outside carbury in June killed
17 seniors we met at the church and
waited and waited n is for nightmare
which is what many in Haiti are living
through the United Nations is supposed
to move in a multinational Force to
fight gang violence early next year
something has to be
done O is for om
this list can't leave out the other
ongoing tragedies in the world
Ukraine Sudan and the Middle East each
too painful India's population has
increased 300% since 1950 P is for
population India actually passed China
as the most populous country in the
world 1.43 billion and growing it's been
branded as Hollywood's Wonder white loss
drug Q is for Q as in people were lining
up for OIC you know Supply couldn't keep
up with
demand think I've too of a girl R is for
rivalry something Taylor Swift and
Beyonce apparently don't have and it's
kind of nice to see they just shot it s
is for spy balloons see the smoke coming
from it they were originally called
unacceptable and irresponsible but may
have been accidental Bob come on down
tea is for television we lost some
Legends of the industry 2023 in front of
the camera behind the
camera and one guy best just described
as a friend I left the message I have
some pride do you
no I'm here today all of you is for
unfortunate I'm not interested in why
the trudos split up I don't want to talk
about it but it was a big story kind
of it's very clear V is for voices we
lost some Legends in 2023 from Tony
Bennett Tina Turner to Jen
[Applause]
Conor this is a historic day and W is
for well we'll see sh Otani signed for
$7 million a year for 10
years and I still remember when my
beloved Expos let Gary Carter go because
he was making $2 million a year this is
a master class and what not to do X is
for
formerly Twitter and formerly better
five of these Tabs are porn one of them
is Twitter that is bad branding biting
the lawn ornament Y is for yarn another
word for story there were a few fun ones
about Bears this year from the human
looking ones in China they were real the
bear was you know playing with the
windshield wiper to a bear stuck in a
minivan in BC there was a real mess it
also left an unbearable stench
and finally Zed is for zest as in for
life we're having fun keeping safe
watching each other's backs I thought
I'd wrap up with one of the people who
fought the fires in the Northwest
Territories this summer and helped us
cover the story he said this videos from
the ground over Facebook nwt strong man
this is my hometown this my this my
country in the months since I've kept
following Aaron Campbell because of the
positivity he pushes just about every
day this week it was about how you're
best best years are in front of you
because you can still make them whatever
you want them to be if you met someone
like that in 2023 it's a good idea to
keep them around for 2024 he's a pretty
good cameraman too happy New
Year what a year indeed and that is
global national for this Wednesday night
I'm Colleen Christie tonight's your
Canada is Newton Manitoba we love to see
your Canada please may email it to
viewers at global national
thanks for watching hope you'll join us
again
[Music]
tomorrow